en 2016 lui rap avec une sorte de
psychodrame politique je dirais avec ce
vote surprise en faveur de la sortie du
royaume uni de l'union européenne ce
fameux exit ça met en lumière
l'incapacité à lyon de l'union
européenne à gérer des crises comme la
fameuse crise migratoire qui sévit sur
le territoire depuis deux ans et ça
vient aussi affaiblir comme tel
la puissance économique de l'union
européenne pendant ce temps on voit la
montée de partis populistes dans
plusieurs pays en europe occidentale et
en europe de l'est en particulier en
allemagne ce sera à surveiller au mois
de septembre et des législatives
et on sait que le parti d'extrême droite
amd a fait des gains énormes au cours
des dernières années à cause justement
de ces problèmes de gestion de crise
migratoire et aussi à cause de ces
attentats qui surviennent comme c'est
arrivé juste avant noël sur le
territoire allemand
ces appuis sont passés de 3 à 15 % au
cours des trois dernières années et
cette année l'allemagne est en élection
générale au mois de septembre
madame merkel sont sa réélection donc
el-oued être assuré pendant ce temps là
on aura aussi en 2017 des élections en
france et on a le même phénomène avec le
parti d'extrême droite de marine le pen
front national qui fait des gains
importants qui est le premier parti
politique en france qui dispose d'appuis
d'à peu près 40 % dans la population et
qui donc pourrait remporter ces
élections présidentielles qui se
tiennent en avril et en mai et on voit
que à côté de ça tous les autres partis
se cherche une voie se cherche une
identité il ya plus de boussole
politique vraiment en france et on voit
que les gens qui vont voter à gauche
peuvent voter à droite maintenant
donc tout ça reste à mesurer une chose
est certaine
l'europe l'avenir comme tel de l'union
européenne est menacée actuellement
[Musique]